bloodshot's that's one of the best mid
movie twists of any superhero flick but
that big reveal comes at a cost there
simply isn't enough time in bloodshot
sure runtime to explain what's real
what's not and how everything fits
together we'd really really like some of
these answers it's impossible to talk
about bloodshot without giving away the
big twist noting that ray garrison
remembers about his past is real his
daring hostage rescue is luxurious
Italian vacation with his beautiful wife
Gina their murder at the hands of a
crazed terrorist all fabrications of
rising spirit technologies the military
contractor has been wiping away Ray's
memories and replacing them with
fantasies designed to make him the
ultimate weapon so then who is ray
bloodshot looks like it's going to tell
us when ray tracks down Gina but doesn't
actually give us any answers
from what Gina says we can infer that
ray really was a member of the military
and really did go on highly classified
missions his name actually is Ray and
his relationship with Gina ended five
years before the movie takes place
that's all we really know nothing about
me you said it right given how much of
the movie seems to hinge on bloodshot's
mistaken identity it's strange that we
didn't get any answers to this question
at all RS t's nanites a miraculous in
many ways not only do they give their
owners superpowers but if you believe
rst founder and lead scientist Emile
hotting they also bring people back from
the dead but is that true as we've seen
it's hard to take dr. Harding at his
word and Ray's death is a fake memory
not only is Ray's real cause of death
left unexplained but it's not even clear
that he actually died in the first place
for example Gina is surprised to see ray
when he shows up an announce at the door
but she's not that surprised it's a kind
of shock that comes from running into a
former lover and expectedly not from
seeing a dead ex-boyfriend suddenly
risen from the grave if Ray had passed
away he'll expect that Gina would have
at least heard about her they're not
together anymore but they clearly still
care about each other unless rst covered
it up and if they did then went back to
the original question what happened that
needed to be kept under wraps
bloodshot isn't actually hunting
terrorists he's tracking down and
killing former rst employees who dr.
Harding fears will spill the company's
secrets to competitors what we don't
know however is why all these people
left there presumably high-paying jobs
doing cutting-edge research in the first
place and for that matter
whydid heart in that everyone go in the
first place when Katie try
the defect parting turns off our implant
making it impossible to leave parting
clearly isn't above using violence to
keep his employees in line why didn't he
stop the problem before it started
rather than force a super soldier to
clean up his mess later by the end of
the film RSC service have been blown to
pieces at CEO and former executives are
all dead and this corporate headquarters
are in shambles for all intents and
purposes it's done and gone it also
collapse in a fairly public fashion to a
superhero broad doesn't happen on a busy
city street without anyone noticing
there's bound to be some cell phone
footage of the fight Alber even Justice
League got that right in the past this
is the sort of thing that rst would have
covered up now though there's nothing
stopping an in-depth investigation from
happening or keeping a lid on the fact
that a military contractor has created
superheroes who now walk among us
repercussions seem inevitable but
bloodshot doesn't offer any clues as to
how they'll play out Gina de Carli still
cares about Rey garrison but she's no
longer in love with him Gina makes that
very very clear when Rey shows up on a
doorstep looking for answers and she
dismisses him with a simple but telling
phrase I have a family that being said
Gina Sims have gotten that family
awfully quickly she broke up with Rey
five years ago that's a very quick time
to get over a major relationship start a
new one get married and have at least
two children one of whom looks like
she's at least four years old
besides that Rey shares one long being
four look of Gina's daughter that
implies this a little more to this story
than Gina is letting on that glance
stands out because it's such a weird
awkward moment and besides why don't we
see Gina's other kid or meet her husband
everything in the way the scene is shot
seems to imply that one if not both of
the kids a race at the same time there's
no real evidence in either the dialogue
or the story to support the theory that
Rey is secretly the child's father is
that just a product of some odd editing
choices or is there something more going
on
Amil hearting lies about everything he
just can't stop himself obviously for a
scheme to work some fibs are necessary
ray needs to believe that his wife was
murdered and that a former rst employee
pulled the trigger
however that doesn't explain everything
when rebooting blood shots it sounds
like a male changes small details and
blood shots origin story just for fun
and we're gonna put this memory in your
head and we're gonna
weaponize you we're gonna get you to do
what we want you to do because we can
take our things backstory for example
when we first meet tarting they're not
so good doctor say so he was a childhood
tennis prodigy who then lost his arm to
cancer the second time however Harting
decides to tell ray he played cricket
not only is that strange but it raises
another question it's any part of
Harding's story true and if not what
really happened to him you figure out
what happened to your arm
nope in fact if Harding is lying about
his own injury who's to say that tips
and Dalton's histories are any more
accurate will they even soldiers not
that it matters too much they're all
dead either way
but it's certainly something to think
about check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
by your favorite superhero films are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bowel so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]